this is the anticipation of finally
licensing a Bitcoin ETF which I'm not as
optimistic will happen overnight but it
does show you that the age of the crypto
Cowboy the FTX and the binance those
days are over this month in the next 10
days they will announce M2 and Abu Dhabi
the largest exchange ever that's
regulated with billions backing it and
tied to huge financial institutions
really what they're going after is
binance will probably lose half of its
accounts to the new M2 because now you
can go off something that the SEC is
suing and go onto a compliant exchange
that's backed by billions of dollars and
huge financial institutions hi Mr
Wonderful here and I am small business
does your company qualify for the
employee retention credit find out at
Wonder trust.com educate yourself with a
live expert at Wonder trust now because
the ERC program is going to end soon